now we are also here we're also here
tonight from congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor green last night she was accosted
in a DC restaurant by two woke liberals
that she is describing as demonic but we
begin tonight with Joe Biden like many
elderly Americans suffering from a very
steep obvious cognitive decline Biden
has good days and he has bad days
unfortunately this week has not been
good at all earlier in Virginia Beach
bidencing completely totally lost Dazed
and Confused you decide
my dad
[Applause]
by the way
you docs are good if there's any angels
in heaven they're all nurses male and
female my plan that's uh and stark
contrast to not by the way there's an
awful lot of really good Republicans but
the mighty Republicans are a different
breed of cat no they're not bad or good
they're just very they're very different
if they have to pay out 150 159
000 billion dollars LED
less for prescription drugs I want to
make it clear I'm going to raise some
taxes
I cannot believe that man is President
can any of you believe that anyway at
one point he drifted not exactly no he
drifted into a very strange long-winded
story about the military nurse named
Pearl yes this is creepy but let's show
you again
when I was at Walter Reed all that time
after a couple craniadines I was lying
there and I had a nurse named Pearl
Nelson military
she'd come in and do things that I don't
think you'll learn the medical school
Nursery School
she'd whisper in my ear I didn't
couldn't understand her she wished when
she'd leaned down
it actually breathed on me to make sure
that I was there was a connection to
human connection
she even went home and brought back her
pillow from her own bed because he
didn't knew the one where I had that
wasn't comfortable
but I'm not joking
not joking and it gets worse because
yesterday Biden was struggling big time
also take a look at this the joy of the
reception which starts after the next
performers that I'm about that's about
to be announced
all right
[Applause]
all right who's gonna not they're going
to announce it
all right anyone understand that now in
case you were wondering uh Joe was at an
event honoring Black History Month and
as you might imagine Biden accidentally
said something pretty racist you decide
again
residents all the presidency
here and I know where the power is
I know where the you think I'm
joking
I may be a white boy but I'm not stupid
um okay I thought we judge people by the
content of their character not the color
of their skin now sadly that type of
rhetoric is nothing new for President
Biden now the woke hysterical word
police and the Democratic party they
elected one of the most bigoted people
in the Washington swamp for example
Biden once worked with segregationists
like Robert KKK Byrd remember he wanted
to stop integration of our Public School
System uh in his words he didn't want
his kids to grow up in a school that is
a racial jungle his best friend and
Mentor was that same Senator Robert Byrd
the former you know Grand Puba of the Ku
Klux Klan and more recently he told
African-Americans that they're not
really black of course unless they vote
for him then he said about Barack Obama
this is Storybook man he's clean he's
bright he's articulate wow that's
storybook for the first time ever he
said if Joe Biden were a republican do
you think the mob and the media would
still support him after all of this take
a look
Madam President we have predators on our
streets you cannot go to a
unless you unless you have an Indian
actually
an accident what kind of a chance with a
Northeastern liberal like Joe Biden
stand uh in the South better than
anybody else and you don't know my state
my state was a slave statement
sort of
mainstream African-American yes who is
articulate and bright and
clean and nice looking guy I mean it's
that's a story they're gonna put you all
back in Chains poor kids are just as
bright and just as tall as white kids we
got more questions you got more
questions but I tell you if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're
familiar Trump and you ain't black
wow now the wolf mob in the Democratic
party they had no problem voting for Joe
they turned out record numbers for that
guy but will they support him again in
2024 now will he even be mentally and
physically capable of serving another
term now the doctor uh first lady Jill
Biden is all in and now reportedly is
pushing Joe to run for that second term
I would only like to remind the bidens
that once again that the White House
this is not their personal retirement
home although he spends 40 percent of
his time in Delaware meeting people that
we have no idea who is meeting because
they don't keep records of it now one
New York Times columnist even suggesting
that Americans may be more inclined to
vote for Joe Biden who soon to be 82 if
he dumps Kamala Harris and chooses a
more popular running mate kind of like
what the ailing FDR did in 1944. hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and mo most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else